when Jeremy corbyn was elected leader of
the labor party in 2015 he promised a
shift in policy on the Middle East
the continuing occupation
the expansion of illegal settlements and
the imprisonment of Palestinian children
are an outrage we will recognize a
Palestinian State as soon as we take
office
when Jeremy corbyn became leader we were
so overdrived at last we have a western
politician who actually sympathizes with
the Palestinians
but soon allegations emerged that he was
a racist the very existence of my part
of the labor party is at stake every
racist anti-same out of the labor party
it's time for Jeremy corbyn to act
the labor files contain the entire
contents of the party's disciplinary
folders since 2014. we can see real
anti-Semitism but then there is also a
lot of information in these disciplinary
files
where there is clearly no anti-Semitism
whatsoever the files show that claims of
anti-Semitism were repeatedly used to
suspend corbyn supporters here is an
example that says we demand that
international criminal court in the U.N
charged Benjamin Netanyahu in Israel for
war crimes against humanity
to suggest that this is somehow
anti-semitic is simply trying to avoid
Israel being called out for its
appalling abuses in the occupied
territories for the first two and a half
years of his leadership it was the party
General Secretary who Corbin inherited
Ian McNichol who was ultimately in
charge of dealing with anti-Semitism
cases
in 2018 Corbin replaced McNichol with an
ally Jenny Formby
analysis of the data in the files tells
a remarkable story
this graph shows the number of
suspensions investigations and
expulsions from the labor party on
grounds of anti-Semitism all through the
corbinera and this is the moment when
Jenny Formby becomes General Secretary
of the labor party enabling Jeremy
corbyn to take control of the
bureaucracy of how Labor Works
after that they took control the number
of Investigations suspensions and
expulsions went up exponentially
under intense pressure corbyn then
accepted a definition of anti-semitism
that includes criticism of Israel
pressure from pro-israel supporters
continued until he was defeated in a
general election in 2019.
soon after new leader sirma takes over
his team meet with leading pro-israel
groups in Britain
the files include minutes of the meeting
which included the board of deputies of
British Jews the board of deputies are
Keen to counter suppositions from labor
MPS that because they're nominally
committed to combating anti-Semitism
that it gives them carte blanche to say
what they like about Israel
Steve Reed a senior opposition Minister
replies that the labor party will never
accept attempts to exceptionalize and
delegitimize Israel
Phil Reese Al Jazeera London